Mr Diamond you've been CEO of JP Morgan
for almost two decades can you explain
why crypto is such an attractive
Financial tool for terrorists drug
traffickers and Rogue Nations I've
always been deeply opposed to crypto
Bitcoin Etc you pointed out the only
true use case for it is criminals drug
traffickers anti-money Laing tax
avoidance you almost Gotta Laugh right
there was never any crime until crypto
came on the scene and it's so crazy
right to see bankers and politicians you
know usually at each other agreeing on
this one crime wow you know in fact uh
some would say crime will go down if you
start to you know use a public Ledger uh
the bottom line though is the question
that we need to be asking is why why are
they so afraid maybe it's because the
system that's being propped up by fiat
currency is a house of cards joining me
now pop Investments investor and Anthony
Pano pop just your thoughts on that I
mean I I cracked up because he's like
you know why do these terrorists love
this stuff well they also love pallets
of billions of dollars that you know
that you give to them as well I look I
think that you nailed it right bad
people are going to do bad things
regardless of the tool the Fiat system
is full of plenty of people doing bad
things the banks themselves have done
plenty of bad things uh JP Morgan over
the last 15 years paid $39 billion in
fines the top big Banks over the last 20
years or so they've paid about 300
billion dollars in fines but also
remember politicians we have a
politician here in New York who was just
charged with wire fraud and credit card
fraud right bad people are going to do
bad things regardless now why are they
scared of it well one is there might be
a lack of Education that would be the
nice way to think about it the other way
is they're threatened by it because it's
competition and if we know anything big
companies love to use regulatory capture
and the best way to use regulatory
capture to compete against someone that
you fear is to get them to make rules
that say you can't do that here and so
Jamie Diamond wants to go ahead and
Stamp Out crypto he has a crypto
Division if he's feels that strongly
about it then shut down your crypto
division before you go after everybody
else right right it's a it's a small
thing just in case this thing works out
at least we have some exposure right but
I I thought when she first when she
initially started speaking I really
thought she was going to say how come
it's performing so well and and you know
that's to me the question is like what's
going on because this was a hell of a
test particularly for Bitcoin uh Gold's
made a pretty good move but let's face
it Bitcoin I think has really separated
itself and has established itself this
year more than any other year that I can
remember as being a quote unquote
legitimate asset yeah I mean look gold
definitely has hit a new all-time high
that's great but it's only up about 13%
for the year the S&P is up 19 so if
you're not outperforming the S&P you
can't really celebrate now on top of
that bitcoin's up over 150% to start the
year and a huge piece of it is just the
market is il liquid 70% of all Bitcoin
circulation has not moved in the year so
if you have people who are crazy enough
that's because people don't want to sell
it of course not but not only are they
not selling as the price moves higher
more and more of them are holding it
normally you see the opposite as price
Rises people sell into the strength so
what you have is people are getting more
conviction on top of that if you go and
you look at retail this is a defined by
people who have one Bitcoin or less in
their wallet they're actually buying up
more Bitcoin in the market than what's
coming in on a net new Supply on a daily
basis so you have retail alone is
pushing the price up and then you get
institutions ETF speculation people
trying to run front run a interest rate
cut and this thing is only going to
continue to run over the next 18 to 24
months you got governments uh El
Salvador is profitable on their Bitcoin
Argentina just had elected someone who
says this you know what get rid of the
old system bring in the new system and
speaking of that you wrote you've talked
about stable coins saving the treasury
market how would that work yeah so if
you look at the treasury market right
now uh supply and demand and right now
there is a big big Supply coming in and
there's not as much demand China and
Japan used to be 22% 10 years ago 22% of
all treasuries were held by China and
Japan today that number is 7% people who
were the dominant uh buyers of
treasuries that we could count on the
United States knew we could always go to
them and they would buy our treasuries
they're not as interested as they used
to be now they're still big holders but
that interest is waning and so when you
say well where is demand going to come
from stable coin issuers today are the
16th largest holder of treasuries so you
look at this you say wait a second here
if this trend continues China Japan and
other countries who have historically
bought our treasuries are going to
continue to decline and we're going to
see this net new demand come from the
digital asset space and I think that
they're going to eventually be a top 10
holder of treasuries why are we going to
ban a top 10 holder of treasuries that
makes no sense and so I just think that
uh as treasury market is down TLT down
22% in The Last 5 Years uh we need
buyers to come from somewhere and if
it's going come from the digital assets
bace so be it so before I let you go
then um you know do you talk targets at
all uh you know I mean you know a
million 200,000 and what are we looking
at Bitcoin what's in the back of your
mind much higher yeah look if you go
back to 2020 I uh wrote out and I said
look it's going to be rocket fuel for
Bitcoin because you're going to get
interest rate Cuts they're going to
print money you're going to get the
having we're setting up for the exact
same thing interest rates are a little
bit higher than they've historically
been over the last 15 years or so
they're going to have to print money and
return to loose monetary policy you're
going to get the ETF uh approval
sometime in q1 and then you're going to
get that having in the beginning of Q2
so you see that is a demand shock a
supply shock bitcoin's price has to go
up to accommodate everyone and I think
that this rally is just the warm-up for
what's going to happen in this Bitcoin
bull market all right buckle up folks
pump you're the man I appreciate you
thank you so much a lot